non-minimalists
so i have a ton of books that i have had
the intention of reading
there's a lot of books i still haven't
read and so i don't know pardon me just
like i don't know if i should get rid of
them
or if i should keep them with an instead
of goal
to read them by a certain time if i
haven't read them
by a certain time then get rid of them
just wanted to get
your input as to how to move forward
well i think there's a couple good
options there you just laid them out
pretty simply here it's your intention
to read them right i think that's why we
bring
books in we usually intend to read them
i've never bought a book that i didn't
intend to
read although i've bought a lot of books
that i never
read before and so i think we need to
set some rules up here now you've
already established that you can do that
right you've said
well should i keep them with a goal that
i'm going to read them
and if that makes sense and you feel
that you can fulfill that
objective then yeah sure why not or or
should i get rid of them
and i think the answer is it really
depends on on your temperament if these
books are
weighing you down if they're getting in
the way if there's a lot of
psychological weight
if they're taking up too much space in
your home and
and that is causing some emotional
weight then i would say by all means
clean slate get rid of them but
if you have some books and you know that
you have an opportunity to read them
they're
they're not just in case items they're
just for when you're able to pick them
up
then yeah i think it's important to set
up a rule to have a a bit of a deadline
and it doesn't have to be the 90 90 rule
which is something we talk about in our
minimalist rule book which
uh we'll give you a copy for free
danielle it's free for everyone actually
the minimalists.com
rule book or if you want the audiobook
version we just did an audiobook version
for that
you can listen to that and it's it's a
different kind of audiobook
we recorded like 16 different mini
podcasts with that
to go along with each of those 16 rules
for living with less but one of those
rules
is the 90 90 rule have i used this in
the last 90 days will
i use it in the next 90 days now a lot
of these books let me pick up one here
this is a book
called anything you want by derek sivers
what a phenomenal book this is and
actually this is one of the there's
maybe three books that i
buy by the case i purchase by the case
and i hand them out to people friends
family etc anyone who i think would find
value from it
and this one in particular i think it's
88 pages of zen
wisdom about business and well
it says it's for entrepreneurs but
anyway this book i can look at it and
say
have i used this in the last 90 days
will i use it in the next 90 days if not
i give myself permission to let go now
maybe 90 days is not the appropriate
timeline
for you with a lot of these books that
you have danielle
of course you haven't used in the last
90 days but maybe it's a one year rule
for you
maybe it's hey am i going to read this
in the next
year now if you want to get strict and
maybe it's 90 days maybe it's 30 days
you give yourself the opportunity to
really
whittle down that collection of books
you're actually going to read within the
next year
and be honest with yourself how many
books are you reading a month
the average person is less than one
which by the way the only
numeral less than one is zero and so
the average person reads next to nothing
and so if you can commit to just reading
one book a year then keep 12 books that
you have
you don't even need to add any more to
the collection and
you can get rid of everything else and
by the way you can always bring
something back in
if you absolutely find that well i miss
this for some reason
now i'll talk to you about some of the
books that i hold on to for longer than
that that fall outside of a
a 90 90 rule and that's a lot of
reference books or just some of my
favorite books today today on the
maximal we're actually going to go over
my my 17
or maybe it's 14 favorite books i
haven't decided which yet
also six books i wish i would have i
would have written
and those books i go back to all the
time one of those books
is right here this is david foster
wallace's first essay collection it's
called a supposedly fun thing i'll never
do again holding this up for the cameras
on
youtube and i think it's a masterpiece
of a book
essays and arguments especially the
experiential essays that
take place throughout this book the
title essay there's another one called a
ticket to the fair it's actually uh
that's the
the shorter version that's the harper's
version but there is a
uh an essay here about the county fair
in illinois which is
hilarious and informative and and
you know there's something about a
collection like that that i keep
going back to i may not read it cover to
cover but i go back to it very regularly
and
my wife hasn't read a whole lot of david
foster wallace so from time to time
when we're doing our morning reading
i'll just pop out one of his books
and dive into an essay read a paragraph
or a page or two
and have that shared experience together
there are other books like reference
books that i use
all the time i mean this book right here
which i'll hold up
is like a door stop getting a workout
just lifting it this is garner's modern
american usage
it's a usage dictionary now it's a
not a dictionary in the traditional
sense like you don't look up words
necessarily
but you look up parts of speech
and it directs you how to better write
how to better use those parts of speech
so as a writer i'll
often look something up uh let me give
you an example i'll just flip to a page
really quickly and here it talks about
compose versus comprise
and what's the difference between we
often use that word comprised
incorrectly right i'll say you know
sean's outfit was comprised of a shirt
shoes and pants that's the incorrect way
to use the word
you would say it's composed right the
and so um a usage dictionary shows you
how to
correctly use standard american english
and so that's something i go back to
regularly there are other books that i
use
as inspiration for when i'm writing and
we're going to go through some of those
on
the maximal episode but daniel i'm going
to move on to another question i hope
you enjoy that copy of
the minimalist rule book either the
audiobook or the free e-book over at the
minimalists.com
rulebook